happy monday everyone i hope you had a
good weekend i certainly had a good
weekend but i'm not sure any of us had
quite so good a weekend as joe biden who
spent it in a tuxedo yucking it up with
the liberal elite at the white house
correspondents association dinner hosted
by trevor noah
take a listen to one joke in particular
that really cracked old joe up
you know i think ever since you've come
into office things are really looking up
you know gas is up rent is up food is up
everything
no it really has been
a tough first year for you mr president
oh man joe sure got a kick out of that
one leans back in his chair claps his
hands you see the joke is everything's
really expensive now
isn't that funny a lot of people are
struggling to fill up their gas tanks
and heat their homes they you know
i'm sorry it's hard to get it's really
hard for some people to buy groceries
and feed their families that's what's
that's just so funny
now it's obviously it's not hard for joe
biden to fill up his gas tank or to buy
groceries to feed his family
he's got millions of dollars which is
kind of weird because he's spent his
whole career in government but he's a
multi-multi-millionaire
that's why he can laugh
okay that's why the people in the room
the white house correspondents
association they can laugh they're no
one's really hurting there
that was
a relatively spicy joke from trevor noah
good on him for making it i guess but
the the rest of the night was just
softballs
even with the inflation joke the crowd
was not laughing at joe biden they were
laughing with joe biden you remember
that distinction don't worry sonny
they're not laughing at you they're
laughing with you well that's what they
were laughing with joe biden it was just
a little good-natured ribbing between
friends and teammates same goes for
biden joe biden wasn't laughing at the
white house correspondents he was
laughing with them too they were all
laughing with each other because the
only people they were laughing at were
us i'm michael knowles that's the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment friday is from shaw of the shine
box who says maxine waters tests
positive for kovid i kind of feel bad
for kovid i agree that is sad i'm glad
i'm glad maxine waters is doing fine we
wish her a full recovery and frankly we
i guess we got to wish the best for
kovid too i wouldn't wish on my worst
enemy that they would catch maxine
waters that would be absolutely terrible
we've got to look out for each other and
for ourselves when you want to do things
yourself especially in your car i'd
recommend you check out rockauto.com
right now go to rockauto.com and type in
knowles in there how did you hear about
us box so they know that we sent you
okay there are a lot of stores that they
just want to sell everything and so they
push products that they don't know
anything about
you you don't want that folks all right
you want to shop at places where the
stores know what they're doing where
they've got expertise where they've been
serving customers for instance online
for 20 years like rock auto whereas a
family business that knows the product
knows what you need will allow you to
easily navigate this huge selection of
parts for your car or truck whether it's
some vintage car whether it's your daily
driver whether you're a pro whether
you're a do-it-yourselfer say same
prices for everybody no gimmicks no
logging in at two in the morning on
tuesday because then you'll get the 10
off no just always reliably low prices
from a company that you can trust that
makes things really easy that has
supported this show from almost the very
beginning one of one of our earliest
sponsors we really appreciate them
you're going to love them too
rockauto.com get the brakes shocks
carpet wipers headlights mirrors
mufflers lug nuts or any other part you
need write nulls in their head did you
hear about us box so they know that we
sent you to them
how should biden have reacted to that
inflation joke that's what people are
going to ask they're going to say oh
michael lighten up come on what was he
going to do
yes it's a bad look
for a joke about record high inflation
record high gas prices record high food
prices things that are really hurting a
lot of americans it's a bad look for
biden to laugh at that but what was he
gonna do
there's actually an answer to this
it's true had joe biden frowned and
grimaced and gotten really angry
that wouldn't have worked that would not
have landed either had he pulled a will
smith and gone up and smacked trevor now
in the face that probably wouldn't have
worked either but likewise he he also
shouldn't have just laughed and gaffawed
and bellied over and clapped his hands
that wasn't a good look either what he
could have done
is is the sort of thing in a in a roast
even or when someone tells an off-color
joke that you don't want to laugh at you
don't want to ascent to but you don't
want to seem like a stick in the mud you
kind of say hey come on
you know you put a little a little bit
of a smile on your face but you say
that's too far hey come on buddy put
your finger out there
a younger joe biden would have gotten
this the reason i'm even focusing on his
reaction here is not because it shows
joe biden to be some evil kind of genius
or any kind of genius he's certainly
never been that it's to show you how
much he's lost of his old political
instinct joe biden of
20 years ago 10 years ago even five
years ago would never have made that
mistake that clip of him laughing at
inflation and laughing at gas prices
going up and laughing at his terrible
economy that's going to be in every
republican campaign ad from now until
november
okay that is going to be plastered
across the airwaves it was a political
misstep joe biden when he had his
marbles or
at least some of his marbles he wouldn't
have fallen into that trap he would have
had a much better political gut
but he he's lost that he we played a
clip last last week on the show
now joe biden blames his senility his
obvious senility on the re-emergence of
a childhood stutter
well look at a clip of him
5 10 20 years ago he didn't have that
stutter i'm not saying he was a rhodes
scholar but the fella could speak
he knew how to read a political scene he
knew how to read a room and slap a back
and smile that that was his political
skill he didn't have that it was really
ugly it did not look good
at the white house correspondents dinner
biden then gets up and reads his jokes
himself the presidents
generally
do pretty well at the white house
correspondents association dinner
because they hire hollywood comedy
writers to write all the jokes for them
so biden gets up and his his sharpest
joke of the night was a joke about the
difference between the modern republican
party and the party of ronald reagan
well i'm not worried about the midterms
i'm not worried about him we may end up
with more partisan gridlock but i'm
confident we can work it out during my
remaining six years of the presidency
i'm not really here to roast the gop
that's not my style besides there's
nothing i can say about the gop that
kevin mccarthy hasn't already put on
tape
at the same
at the same time a lot of people say the
republican party is too extreme too
divisive to controlled by one person
they say it's not your father's
republican party
ronald reagan said mr gorbachev tear
this wall down
today's republicans say tear down mickey
mouse's house
and pretty soon they'll be storming
cinderella's castle you can be sure of
it
but republicans
seem to support one fella
some guy named brandon
he's having a really good year
and i'm kind of happy for him
delivery is not what it once was not
exactly don rickles up there but you get
the joke the joke and he didn't even get
the line right by the way it's probably
four of the most famous words in
american history tear down this wall
mr gorbachev tear down this wall and
biden couldn't even remember that though
he was in the united states senate at
the time but he says okay the old gop
said
mr gorbachev tear this wall down and the
modern gop says tear down cinderella's
castle
but
even that joke underscores a big
political weakness for democrats right
now yes during the cold war the
conservatives were unified focusing on
problems overseas because you had a
threat from the soviet union
you had the threat of the cold war
once the berlin wall fell down
then there was a cold war that was being
waged not around the globe but a cold
cultural war that was being raged at
home
that has become hot on many occasions
why is it that modern-day republicans
are saying mr disney tear down
cinderella's castle because the walt
disney corporation is trying to trans
little kids it's not just disney that's
supporting this it's pretty much every
corporation and it's teachers all the
way down to kindergarten and preschool
who are now insistent with the support
of elected democrats up to and including
joe biden up to and including all of the
white house agencies saying it is
essential health care it is it is so
important for five-year-olds to be put
on puberty blockers cross-sex hormones
potentially have their bodies mutilated
if little boys think they're little
girls that's that's the joke
these modern republicans
they don't even think we should chop off
five-year-olds genitals
uh yeah
and the white house correspondents
association they're all laughing because
they're all pro
mutilate little kids bodies they're all
pro put little boys on cross-sex
hormones and little girls on
testosterone they're they're all in
favor of that and they don't realize
how
completely out of touch they are with
the rest of america not just with
republicans not just with conservatives
but with parents everywhere all around
the country they don't even get it if
you want to be able to
tell jokes
you need to have some
connection to the common sense
you need
you need the things that you're saying
to resonate with people
ordinary common people not just whacked
out liberals who think that it's a good
idea to transgender five-year-olds and
they have lost that common sense and
this is not my own wish casting this is
not my own ideological view of things
i'm just one looking at common sense two
looking at tradition and three looking
at the poll numbers there's a marist
poll that just came out
of voting preferences among parents of
kids under 18.
so when you loses a poll of 1300
national registered voters that just
took place a couple of weeks ago
when you look at just
voters who have children under the age
of 18 they are twice as likely to vote
for republicans as for democrats
that so please joe keep telling that
joke bring it on
because the joke ultimately is going to
be on you it's going to be on the
democrats it's going to be on the white
house correspondents association and
biden and big tech and the media and the
whole thing
it's just all the liberal blob
now maybe they rigged the election and
it wouldn't
wouldn't be the first time
but absent some true shenanigans absent
some
suspension of the ordinary election
rules and getting rid of the poll
watchers and changing the violating the
state constitution certain places absent
that kind of
active rigging of the election right now
if you look at the poll numbers and you
look at the way that the democrats are
campaigning including in their jokes
including all the way up to joe biden
the democrats are in for a tsunami
come
november
on all of these issues on the on the
economy on immigration on education and
especially on life which is why you've
got to check out 40 days for life go to
40daysforlife.com for
zerodaysforlife.com
abortion is always a really really big
issue in our politics it's very
important issue of course if you want to
defend life but it's about to become
even more urgent because the supreme
court is going to come out with its
decision and dubs versus jackson women's
health and and this is going to decide
whether or not to overturn roe vs wade
you need the arguments okay you need to
know what this is about how to respond
to people when they bring up this issue
well 40 days for life has the number two
amazon christian bestseller what to say
when the complete new guide to
discussing abortion how to change minds
and convert hearts in a brave new world
these guys are based in texas one of the
largest pro-life grassroots
organizations in the world they've got a
million volunteers in 1 000 cities
holding peaceful 40-day vigils outside
of abortion mills to save lives and help
abortion workers leave those jobs get
the book what to say when today covers
the old arguments covers the new
arguments get it and check out
40daysforlife.com
to help end abortion wherever you live
biden then rounded out his white house
correspondents association appearance by
making a joke about the vaccine
and making a joke specifically about fox
news for the democrats fox news
has been the main target for a long time
i think probably the media landscape has
changed a lot
so
among conservatives you wouldn't you
wouldn't say as you might have 20 20 or
25 years ago that fox news is the only
or even the main conservative outlet
there in the culture that was true when
we were a television culture but we're
now 20 years more than 20 years into the
internet age so that i think that's
changed pretty significantly joe biden
though obviously is not the most
up-to-date fella on the planet so he
makes this joke about fox news it was a
really ugly joke about fox news he said
ha ha ha everyone in this room is vaxxed
tonight including and especially those
fox news people who had to take it
i know they're questions about whether
we should gather here tonight because of
covet well
we're here to show the country that
we're getting through this pandemic plus
everyone had to prove
they were fully vaccinated and boosted
so if you're at home watching this
and you're wondering how to do that
just contact your favorite fox news
reporter they're all here
vaccinated and boosted all of
them so the joke you see is that these
people these
pro maybe conservatives you know fox
news actually employs a lot of liberals
too but it's certainly the most
conservative of the main tv channels
fox news reporters who maybe didn't want
to get the vaccine had to get the
vaccine because joe biden made him
made them do it and then joe biden's
administration made them do it and then
some corporate leaders made them do it
too haha that's the joke
you didn't want to get this experimental
drug that doesn't do the very things
that we were told by joe biden in
particular that they would do yeah you
didn't want to get that injected into
you to protect you against a virus that
poses pretty much an infinitesimally
small threat to you well ha ha joke's on
you i'm making you do it i made you
inject yourself with an experimental
drug
that's the that's the joke that's the
joke is i
violated your rights
and made you inject yourself with
something that probably isn't going to
do you a whole lot of good and might do
you a little bit of harm actually
that that's the joke that's called an
abuse of power
evil is that
by the way you know i'm not even against
vaccine mandates generally
but
we're not talking about the black death
here folks we're not talking about a
virus that poses a great risk to lots
and lots of people and we're not talking
about an ordinary vaccine we're not
talking about a vaccine that will even
do the basic thing that a vaccine is
supposed to do which is to prevent you
from contracting or transmitting a virus
the very thing that biden wallenski and
voucher told us the vaccine would do
before they admitted that the vaccines
won't do that
how evil is that and then to mock
someone say haha i made you take the
shot
especially ironic because just last week
joe biden was waxing philosophic about
how he thinks that the greatest sin
imaginable is the abuse of power
when we were talking about the way over
what got me involved in politics i got
on politics involved in politics because
i think the greatest sin anyone can
commit
is the abuse of power
whatever that power is the power of a
teacher the power of
a doctor the power of a leader
when someone who is relying on you or
you cannot
just the abuse of power that's the it's
the abuse of power unless i'm abusing
power against my political enemies then
it's great then i love it funny too that
biden says that the issue that got me
into politics
ish it was the abuse of power
the week before that the one week before
joe biden said that
he told a different story and he said
that the issue that got him into
politics was the environment
before joe biden did that he said that
the issue that got him into politics was
civil rights before joe biden said that
he said the issue that got him into
politics was voting rights now in joe
biden's defense he probably doesn't
remember
either what he's been saying or what
issue got him into politics
but he also doesn't care
he doesn't care he'll just lie he'll
just say anything he'll smack backs he's
he is such a
fluent liar
he's such a practice liar that i'm not
sure that he can tell the difference
between lies and truth anymore
and and now he says it's the the abuse
of power that's the thing
joe biden
who we also mentioned last week has an
unexplained five million dollars more
than five million dollars in his bank
account
there there is a discrepancy on his
financial disclosures he hasn't
explained how he got that money hunter
biden's laptop might explain how he got
that money because hunter biden was
peddling joe's influence overseas in
ukraine and china among other places to
get sweetheart deals from crooked
oligarchs who would then try to buy his
father's influence his father who was
then the vice president of the united
states now the president selling
america's interests down the river but
the worst sin imaginable is the abuse of
power so he says speaking of power
it must be a chilly day in hell it's a
temperate day here in nashville
tennessee
in many other parts of the country but
in hell it's got to be a very chilly day
because
the most prominent leftist intellectual
of perhaps the last
50 years
noam chomsky
was asked a question about
foreign relations in particular the war
in ukraine
and noam chomsky said that there is one
statesman above all the others who
deserves credit and and praise and
and uh
well that we should copy this statesman
and hear what he has to say and actually
put it into effect is noam chomsky as
left-wing as they come saying that that
statesman is
donald j trump
well there is
fortunately
one
statesman
in the united states and europe who has
laid out
a person of a high political figure who
has made a very sensible statement about
how you can solve the crisis
namely by
facilitating negotiations
instead of undermining them
and moving towards establishing
some kind of accommodation in europe
maybe a long
in which there are no military alliances
which is mutual accommodation he didn't
mention all of this
but he suggested something similar
move towards negotiations and diplomacy
instead of escalating the war
uh try to see if he can bring about an
accommodation
uh
which would be roughly along these lines
his name is
donald j trump
donald j trump you never thought you
would hear it noam chomsky a virulent
critic of trump and of conservatives
since what the 1950s as you can hear
from his voice and if you're watching
this as you can see noam chomsky is now
about 175 years old he is father time
now but he remains as sharp as he ever
was
jamski's wrong about a billion things
especially when it comes to politics but
no one's ever accused him of being dumb
he's one of the most intelligent people
in the country
and i mentioned this not to say that
what trump is doing on ukraine and
russia is even correct it's sort of
outside of the issue of ukraine and
russia the reason i bring this up
is to underscore something that we have
seen go on for six years now namely a
realignment of the political parties
when i was a kid
republicans were the party of pro-war
democrats were the party of anti-war
today that has shifted when i was a kid
republicans were the party of spread
american liberal imperialism around the
world democrats were the party of no
just focus on things at home
today that has shifted when i was a kid
republicans were the party of big mega
corporations democrats were the party
against those big corporations and for
keeping things small and at home and
focused on workers today that has
completely flipped when i was a kid
republicans were the party of
outsourcing american jobs democrats were
the party of workers rights today that
has completely flipped
the list goes on
and on and on
this is a real realignment this is a
real opportunity
for republicans to make big gains here
and it hinges on one other big
difference by the way when i was a kid
republicans were the party of never
wielding political power so the people
elect republicans and then republicans
don't do very much they would sometimes
explicitly run on the slogan of elect me
and i won't do anything yuck yuck yuck
we need the government to be so small it
fits in your pocket
and democrats were the party of a big
government now we don't want small
government or big government at least i
don't we want limited government and we
want an energetic government within the
legitimate bounds of that government
today
republicans are starting to get this
republicans notably ron desantis in
florida recognizes that when republicans
get elected they need to do stuff they
need to go and they need to change the
curricula in the schools they need to go
and they need to wield government power
when corporations are undermining the
will of florida voters they need to go
in they need to
use the government power to oppose
federal mandates they need to go in and
do stuff
with the political power that people
give them within legitimate boundaries
that's a big flip that's all good news
for republicans if they can learn what
time it is and and put those dirty
rotten swamp creatures in their place
who don't want to actually do something
if they actually want to ascend and
become major political players in the
united states
i think we're doing it right now i think
we can look good doing it the way we can
look good doing it is when we wear
mizzen and main right now go to
mizzenandmane.com use promo code knowles
that's m m-i-z-z-e-n
and maine.com you gotta go there because
their clothing not only feels great but
it looks magnificent i just had my
beautiful mizzen and made polo out the
other day i was wearing it because
being of italian extraction i am known
to perspire a little bit their their
clothing has all of the comfort of
athletic wear you're not going to be
just swimming in sweat as the summer
comes on you
but they look really really great they
look really chic really sophisticated
really put together the lightweight
breathable moisture wicking you're going
to love it they're machine washable so
you don't need to worry about going to
the dry cleaner and they just look good
so many modern clothing companies just
look terrible and they turn people into
just
robots or something i
missing in maine really understands
style giving you a little bit of flair
this summer whether you're working from
the golf course or finally taking
advantage of that unlimited vacation
policy
right now you've got to go to mizin and
maine.com use promo code and also get 35
off any regular price order of 125 or
more that's 35 bucks off when you go to
m-i-z-z-e-n-a-n-d-m-a-i-n-dot-com
promo code knowles
you want to know how the united states
got to this point two years after a
ridiculous lockdown for a virus the
origins of which are a little bit
dubious and actually it seems like the
ruling class is not telling us
everything about it well you can find
out answers to all those questions and
many more in my series fouchy unmasked
all episodes are streaming now
the the series will tell you things that
you have never heard before about this
guy that will show you clips of this guy
that will go into depth not just on what
fouchy's done for the last two years but
all the way back to the 1980s things
that the ruling establishment does not
want you to find out about clips that i
that i had played a year ago that i had
seen that i couldn't even find when i
went back to search for them that is how
much the liberals are trying to memory
hold fauci and his huge power grab don't
let them do it check out the sneak peek
he's the highest paid employee in our
federal government
and beginning in the spring of 2020 dr
fauci began to set national policy that
affected the way that 330 million
americans lived their lives for goodness
sakes i'm telling you wear a mask
keep social distancing there's nothing
political about that but who is anthony
fauci people who have conspiracy
theories those are people that don't
particularly care for me in this short
series
we will do what the establishment media
have refused to do
we will give you an unvarnished look at
the career of the most powerful
politician in america
dr anthony thatcher don't you think it's
time that you step down and let someone
else who has a more effective message
actually no
[Music]
actually no i don't think i should step
down well we think you should the full
series is available now exclusively for
daily wire members if you're not a
member yet head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe for a limited time members can
use code knowles k-n-o-w-l-e-s
for 20 off your membership go check it
out this is only for members and when
you use code nulls it will really
irritate ben so that's the number one
reason you should do it and the number
two reason you'll save 20
do not miss it right now daleyware.com
subscribe code knowles we'll be right
back with a lot more
speaking of russia and ukraine really
unsettling news has come out of there in
the last four or five days russia is
shutting off natural gas to poland and
bulgaria the reason that russia is
shutting off its gas to poland and
bulgaria is because those countries are
refusing to pay for the gas in rubles
previously before joe biden made a
gigantic mess of the entire world
previously you would pay for gas and oil
and things in dollars in the us dollar
and then
joe biden literally invited russia to
invade ukraine and then they responded
too late to that invasion by going after
the russian ruble and after the bank in
russia and after the russian economy
russia retaliated by saying okay if you
want to buy our gas now you've got to
you've got to pay for it in rubles
and this is creating a very awkward
situation for some of russia's
energy consumers who don't want to help
out russia but they're hooked on the gas
and the oil why are they hooked on the
gas and oil well in part you want to
talk about russian disinformation and
propaganda russia has had a well-known
highly publicized
disinformation campaign to support
left-wing environmentalist groups in
recent decades to convince europe and
the united states and the west not to
produce their own energy so that they're
more hooked on russian energy
this is not some crazy conspiracy theory
the russians have been actually been
pretty open about this campaign and it's
worked and so now russia's got europe
and the us even and the west over a
barrel
and there there
are not going to be a whole lot of
options for poland for bulgaria for
germany perhaps for other western
countries who need the oil even the
united states we get what about 10 of
our
imported oil from russia
it's a big problem
so what do we do here
well this should be a reminder for those
of you who hadn't noticed it before i'm
sure you have but unfortunately biden
and his lackeys have not noticed it the
only real deterrent is strength
that's the only deterrent
this is really simple stuff ronald
reagan put it very well we're going to
peace through strength
and people misinterpret that statement
in all sorts of ways they think peace
through strength means we need to send
the american military all around the
world to manage a global empire that's
not what peace through strength means
necessarily
peace through strength is that we've got
to go preemptively attack other
countries no that's not what peace
through strength is it's really basic
we need to be strong we're not gonna
we're not gonna pull a fast one on
vladimir putin
or on xi jinping oron the ayatollah in
iran or on anyone else we're not going
to pull a fast one and do a jedi mind
trick and convince them
that we have far greater leverage in
world affairs than we actually do
the the strongest
way to
maintain your leverage around the world
is to actually have leverage this is
always the funniest thing with russian
misinformation and disinformation this
was the liberal argument against the
hunter biden laptop they said the 100
biden laptop that's russian
disinformation then we find out that the
the laptop is totally legit and it's
actually got pictures of under biden
it's got his files his letters his
spreadsheets and what the the liberals
will still continue to argue is well
yeah it's all true but it was released
as part of russian disinformation in
other words
they're saying that they're saying
something that is in fact true the best
propaganda
happens to be the propaganda that's true
do you remember a month or two ago we
were talking about the bio labs in
ukraine
and on this show i put my nostradamus
out i got out my crystal ball and i said
you know the united states is funding
and in part operating
biological labs that are working on
pretty dodgy biological materials
from old soviet-era bioweapons
laboratories uh we're we're working on
those things in ukraine and elsewhere in
eastern europe and what happened the
liberal establishment said this is false
this is disinformation this isn't true
this is crazy this is coming from the
kremlin you're all pro-putin russian
puppets they said no i'm just telling
the truth this is actually happening and
finally when it was uncovered that it
was true the lib said okay well yeah
it's true but it's still kremlin
propaganda and that's actually a good
point yes the most effective propaganda
is the propaganda that happens to be
true
yes you can't just you can't just say
well such and such is propaganda ignore
it move along nothing to see here no
really sophisticated propaganda
operations deal with things that are
true
okay and so you're not going to get away
this ties back into the
oil and gas here because you're not
going to get away
with illusions and mirages and little
parlor tricks if if we want the united
states to be strong around the world and
not have to worry necessarily about what
russia is doing or what iran's doing or
if if we want real strength around the
world
there's one way to do it
produce our own oil
produce our own gas
make our own energy then we will have
real leverage
and we won't need to do this little song
and dance that biden's trying to do
that's obviously not working anywhere
that's why trevor noah makes the joke
everything's looking up since you're
president gas is looking up food is
looking up ha ha i guess it is right
well biden promised us that that
everything would be improving if he were
elected president
international affairs the economy
energy
list goes on and on none of those things
have improved because biden's it's
pretty simple biden's policy is a policy
of weakness on all of those weakness at
the border weakness on energy weakness
on the economy weakness on foreign
affairs and weakness gives you really
bad stuff speaking of problems overseas
this was a very distressing news story
for me
as someone of italian and sicilian
heritage
little babies in italy
will no longer be given their father's
last name
the italian constitutional court
has dropped the convention for naming
that has existed in italy and every
other civilized country for a very very
long time
namely when a baby is born you know it's
true here
the baby is automatically given the
father's last name
you can change it you can go in and ask
for a special exception but the
convention is you get your father's last
name now
italy's constitutional court
has said that this is quote
discriminatory discriminatory and
harmful to the identity of the child
and that the the court said children
should be given both parents last names
in whichever order the parents decide
unless the parents agree
to use just one one in other words the
babies in italy will no longer simply
have their father's last name they will
also have their mother's father's last
name ha-ha take that patriarchy yeah
that you thought it was just daddy's
world well now it's also daddy-in-law's
world yeah that's a so
just on its face this is a very
silly
change
because it does nothing for feminism it
does nothing for women
it doesn't even do the thing that it
says it's going to do namely give the
baby a woman's last name because the
woman got her last name from a man but
what this is really about
is an attack on the integrity of the
family people sometimes write into the
mailbag they say hey michael i'm getting
married and should should i take my
husband's last name or should i ask my
wife to take my last name
previously
you wouldn't even get this question this
would just be common sense of course i'm
going to take my husband's last name but
now it's not so common now it's not
really known whether or not you're going
to do that
of course you should do that the reason
you should do that is not only because
of the silly father-in-law thing but
also because
you are now in a family
when you get married you are deciding
that the groom is going to leave his
family and the bride is going to leave
her family and you're going to come
together and create a new family and
that new family is going to be a
discreet entity and what god has joined
let no man separate and that discreet
entity needs to have
cohesion it needs to have coherence
that's why you all share the name
when
in in the older and i think proper
convention as i still write letters this
way and i still receive letters this way
but i know it's not as common these days
if i'm writing to
john and jane smith i'll write
to mr and mrs john smith
when i receive letters often it's to mr
and mrs michael knowles is this because
my wife has lost her first name
no sweet little still has her first name
but we are we are one flesh we are one
family we have a discreet identity now
and the reason the libs are pushing for
this obviously it's not
to advance feminism it doesn't advance
feminism all it does is break up the
integrity of the family
and this is a problem for the left in
particular because the left hates the
family but the right hasn't done a very
good job defending the family
the left says that the basic unit of
society is the individual and then we've
got to collect all the individuals
together in a collective in a socialist
program or a communist program or
whatever and that's how we're going to
organize society
the right until recently
for i would say from probably 1970 until
about five or six years ago the right
would say the basic unit of society is
the individual they would say the same
damn thing that the left would say but
they instead of saying then we all need
to collectivize they would say no we
just need to remain individuals
so you get you get the left saying we
need individuals to a collective the
right says just remain individuals
they're two sides of the same coin
that's not really an alternative it's a
it's a parlor trick it's it's a false
dichotomy the actual alternative view of
society
is that you've got the the left and the
hyper individualist right saying the
basic units of politics is the
individual and then the actual
conservatives would say no the basic
unit of politics is the family
ben has been talking about this he's
been he's been great on this especially
in recent weeks he's been talking about
this
that the the family is the fundamental
he says the fundamental economic unit
you can go even further it's the
fundamental political unit so any way to
drive division within the family any way
to try to redefine the family is an
attack
by the left and by complicit and naive
and ignorant right wingers on the right
on conservatism
speaking of family more bad news sorry
to tell you folks even stateside
no one's really talking about this
but it's worrying me
there is now evidence from the supreme
court if you're paying close attention
to what the court is doing
that john roberts the chief justice will
not be writing the decision in the big
abortion case that's coming before the
court
dobbs versus jackson women's health
is the big case that could overturn roe
vs wade could overturn planned
parenthood v casey could get rid of the
fictional constitutional right to an
abortion that the court found in 1973
but there is evidence that the chief
justice is not going to be writing the
majority opinion there why because
the chief justice wrote the opinion for
the 6-3 majority in a different case
cummings versus premier rehab keller
which was a case involving recovery of
damages under obamacare
or the rehabilitation act of 1973
court watchers the people who are paying
really really close attention here are
saying that because roberts already
wrote two other majority opinions during
the court's current term he probably
won't write the majority for the
abortion case because that means that
one of the justices on the court won't
be writing any of the opinions which
would be uncommon
now what does all of that mean
some people are saying oh this is a good
thing this means that maybe clarence
thomas will write the majority if the
the conservatives win on that case and
if roe v wade is overturned and if the
pro-lifers win
i don't i don't really see that
because if so
if the conservatives are going to win
uh if the pro-lifers are going to win if
we're going to overturn roe versus wade
we know that clarence thomas is going to
vote for it we know that sam alito is
going to vote for it
we think that brett kavanaugh is going
to vote for it
we think that amy coney barrett is going
to vote for it
we think that neil gorsuch is going to
vote for it so there you go that's five
votes and i would have assumed at that
point
that john roberts is going to side with
the conservatives because either you're
going to get a 5-4 decision or you're
going to get a 6-3 decision if it's a
6-3 decision then
very likely it would be john roberts
who's writing the the opinion of the
court john roberts would write the
opinion of the court so that he can give
a more moderate opinion a less expansive
one a less radical one otherwise
clarence thomas who's the senior most
judge is going to be writing the opinion
for the for the conservative side i
don't think john roberts is going to
allow clarence thomas to do that so all
of this is very in the weeds and i am
reading tea leaves a little bit here
i'm not making any firm predictions i'm
not putting on my nostradamus hat but it
makes me worried
if roberts is not writing the majority
opinion in dubs versus jackson women's
health it makes me worried that maybe
they're not going to uphold the
mississippi pro-life law maybe they're
not going to overturn roe versus wade
i'm not saying anything definitively i'm
just saying i am now more worried about
that case than i was
two or three weeks ago
speaking of the deaths of innocent
people
really spooky news story just came out
of cbs police found 150 skulls at a
crime scene in mexico
you say well not that's a it's a little
excessive but given the way the cartels
operate in mexico i guess it's not
totally surprising except it turns out
the skulls are not recent it's not
because these cartels were shuffling
drugs and people across the border turns
out that the skulls were from
over 1 000 years ago
the skulls were mostly of women and they
were ritually decapitated
by the native americans who inhabited
who inhabited mexico over a thousand
years ago
now this is very strange
because i went to school in the 1990s
and 2000s i was reliably informed
according to the liberal curricula that
were prevalent at that time and remain
prevalent today that the native
americans were all just living kumbaya
like in avatar and they were all just so
peaceful and they used every part of the
buffalo and everything was really great
it was just an edenic wonderland until
the evil white man got here those
spanish conquistadors who brought death
and evil and destruction and violence to
the new world and destroyed this
paradise that was here well hold on
what do you mean they were ritually
decapitating 1 000 women at a clip
before the conquist are you telling me
that possibly
those native american tribes that the
westerners civilized are you telling me
that they were not
they were not just uh living in a total
paradise in utopia i think that might be
what the news and reality is telling us
the way that history is taught these
days
is so
stupid it's so contrary to reality and
the people who get short shrift are the
founding fathers for sure and
christopher columbus especially and
maybe even more than columbus the
conquistadors the way that the the
spanish explorers who made it to latin
america and
conquered the the different uh
tribes and
sort of civilizations there
they get really short shrift we are told
that these are evil awful people who had
no business being here and no right to
come in and take over those territories
and the poor beleaguered indigenous
people deserve reparations from modern
day spaniards and everyone else
the the reality of
the
pre-pre-columbian pre-western
civilizations in the americas is very
different
the aztecs in particular i'll just use
the aztecs as one example conquered by
cortez the aztecs at the consecration of
tenochtitlan
ritually sacrificed over 80 000 people
in the span of four days lots of women
lots of children ripped their beating
hearts out of their chests and then
kicked their bodies down the side of the
pyramids
they were
and it wasn't just the aztecs though
they were probably the worst of them
they were some of the most evil
societies that have ever existed on the
face of the earth the the practices that
they engaged in cried out to heaven and
the brave western explorers who
conquered them are some of the greatest
heroes in history
just at one site
1 000 years ago you had how many skulls
150 skulls
of just of these poor innocent women who
had their heads chopped off and that's
nothing compared to what the aztecs were
doing at tenochtitlan and what what
other of these so why is it being taught
this way
it's being taught this way because there
is no
moral foundation for how to view history
anymore
or there's not a coherent moral
foundation at least
what if you walked into a history class
in high school or even college right now
and you said those conquistadors were
great go them they were awesome
they should they should have slaughtered
every single aztec leader that they came
across and and they did slaughter a lot
of them good good on them you would be
kicked out of class if you said that on
social media you might be kicked off of
social media and yet it's obviously true
it's it's like saying that uh you know a
good cowboy walked in and saw you know
an evil gang raping women and killing
people and committing all sorts of
abuses and then he went out and killed
the bad guys
except on a much larger scale when we're
talking about
the aztecs and other civilizations you
know pre-columbus in in the americas
but we're not allowed to say that
because the westerners had no right to
be here and we're not allowed to make
any moral judgments and we have cultural
relativism and who's to say you know one
man's uh ritualistic decapitation is
another man's
you know sunday afternoon in the park
the only way that we are going this has
bearing for politics because
yes it matters
with regard to how we read and teach
history but what it really matters for
how we live today
we have to make moral judgments we have
to make moral distinctions we have to be
able to say no the thing that this
culture is doing is bad and they should
stop doing it
and and
maybe even more importantly we need to
be able to look at our civilization
which we have been now indoctrinated
into viewing as just entirely and
irredeemably evil
for the past 50 years because of
radicals who hate our civilization and
want to destroy it they've convinced us
to hate our own civilization why it's
the greatest civilization in the history
of the world
in many ways it's the only civilization
in the history of the world certainly to
reach the heights that ours has
that's a good thing we need to recover
our confidence
not it's actually not enough to just say
other people are doing things that are
wrong what that implies is that we are
doing something that is right and if
we're doing something that is wrong we
need to be able to rectify that but in
order to
in order to enact justice in our own
country and around the world we need to
have some sense of the difference
between good and bad right and wrong
speaking of latin america
the leader of brazil just got into a
little bit of a smackdown with leonardo
dicaprio dicaprio is trying to oust the
president of brazil
bolsonaro
dicaprio tweets out quote brazil is home
to the amazon and other ecosystems
critical to climate change uh what
happens there matters to us all and
youth voting is key in driving change
for a healthy planet for more on voter
registration in brazil before may 4th
visit blahblahblah.whatever.com
now
bolsonaro comes out
this is the leader jair bolsonaro
he says thanks for your support leo it's
really important to have every brazilian
voting in the coming elections our
people will decide if they want to keep
our sovereignty on the amazon or to be
ruled by crooks who serve for special
interests good job in the revenant
a great response here because one
leonardo dicaprio is a huge hypocrite
when it comes to climate change climate
change quote unquote you know the sun
monster and everything he flies around
in private jets he consumes a ton more
energy than than most other people
and yet he has the gall and the audacity
to lecture all the rest of us but
furthermore furthermore
it tells you something about the way
politics works around the world and even
here at home when the brazilian people
elect
bolsonaro we are told that's a threat to
democracy
when some hollywood elite who has
absolutely no connection to brazil
flies in on his private jet and tells
the brazilian people that what they're
doing is wrong and they need to do what
he says instead that's called
pro-democracy
when the american people elect donald
trump that's a threat to democracy when
a handful of deep state crooks decide to
try to overturn that election for four
years that's called pro-democracy
how is that because democracy when the
libs use that word just means liberalism
just means progressivism leftism
whatever you want to call it
the ruling class
and when
so so when people vote for them by
definition that's pro-democracy when the
people vote against them that is
anti-democracy even though it is in
itself a democratic act
this is this is how you can make sense
of the white house correspondents
association dinner
at the white house correspondents
association one of the big jokes that
joe biden told us he said this is the
first time in six years the president's
been here
because donald trump wouldn't come here
and they all applauded him good job
you're showing up here right he's
showing up because that's his team
they're all on the same team donald
trump didn't show up there not because
he's thin skinned he can't take a joke
he's taken a lot of jokes he's a
professional entertainer he didn't show
up there because he knew that was a
rigged game
it was dumb for conservatives who oppose
the ruling ideology to show up there
because it's it's just a farce it's a
joke they're all on the same team
they're all on the same side they all
want exactly the same thing they're all
going to abuse their power to cover up
for one another
why show up there when when biden is
yucking it up with the white house
correspondents association it is the
clearest demonstration we've had in a
long time of the the real two sides in
american politics and it's not
republican versus democrat it's not just
left versus right it is a ruling class
that enriches itself and it sconces
itself in power versus
the american people who are on the other
side of that and it's
it overlaps with the left and the right
it overlaps with republican and democrat
but there is a club there is a club
folks and when joe biden's yucking it up
it's a reminder you ain't in it i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
today on the ben shapiro show the white
house correspondents dinner features
america's political elites mocking you
the biden administration proposes their
ministry of truth and the new york times
puts out a hit on tucker carlson that's
today on the bench bureau show give it a
listen